January can be pretty darn quiet for
videogames but you don't just have to
sit around and wait for cyberpunk 2077
all comb through your pile of 2019 games
you didn't quite get to all think about
the new year's resolutions you've
already given up on because this year
has a whole bunch of really exciting
looking games on the way whether you've
forgotten these titles are on the way or
they never hit your radar here are seven
wildly unique games coming out in 2020
that you'll probably want to keep an eye
out for since you're sitting here
listening to my Australian accent let me
kick off by telling you about an
Australian game I first spotted way to
the woods alongside a few thousand other
people when it's then 16 year old
developer Anthony Tam posted screenshots
of the game to read it four years ago
weight of the woods was shown off again
recently with the trailer you're
currently watching during Xboxes III
press conference last year the game will
launch on Xbox one and PC though it's
worth noting it'll also be available on
xbox game pass at launch the very pretty
adventure game will center around Adia
and its faun who are as the title would
suggest on their way to the woods it
looks to feature environmental puzzling
a wonderful soundtrack and a journey
esque ping system that you'll use to
absorb light so long as this game
doesn't go the way of Bambi I'm so down
for it onto another game with a great
art style the pathless was originally
slated for a 2019 release after its
reveal trailer at the game awards in
2018 but given that it's the next game
from the team that made obsolete than
never the pathless looks to be
significantly darker in tone than Abzu
unless you count the scary shock bits
but just as beautiful the protagonist is
a bow wielding adventurer with an eagle
companion who comes up against a giant
lava Laden foes that look like what
you'd expect from the mind of developer
giant squid the developer intends to
incorporate more traditional gameplay
elements this time around though it is
maintaining its trend of unconventional
controls in the pathless that'll mean
you don't have to aim because the team
wants players to feel like they share
the talents of an expert hunter the
pathless is coming to ps4 and PC if you
want to drop further into more
mind-bending terror
twelve minutes could be the 20/20 game
for year you play as a husband who is
stuck in a Groundhog Day situation where
you keep reliving the same 12 minute
period when you arrived home a police
detective breaks in and accuses your
pregnant wife of murder the kubrik
inspired interactive thriller by louis
antonio turned a lot of heads when it
was shown off at Xboxes III press
conference last year due to its a unique
top-down perspective and unusual
narrative structure where your character
learns from his previous runs so new
options for dialogue and actions open up
as you go demo is available to the media
during e3 last year revealed that the
game's main story takes six to eight
hours to complete suggesting there is
plenty to be unearthed beneath the
surface of 12 minutes as for games that
are perfectly suited for your downtime
Animal Crossing inspired crafting
simulator Monaco's night market is just
oozing charm and headed to PC and
Nintendo switch later this year the game
is full of townspeople to meet goods to
sell minigames to play
cats to harvest yes you heard that right
and artifacts to uncover among so many
other things if the trailer is anything
to go by the art style is adorable the
music is jamming and this sure does look
like a game that might be swallowing a
lot of your time next year especially if
you like cats because boy are there a
lot of cats though with the developer
called meows the games I don't know what
else you expected if this was all
getting a little cutesy for you at this
point in the video then do I have the
180 for you because this next one is
phobia game studios reverse horror game
carrion where you play as an amorphous
creature that brutally kills everybody
yeah this is not a smooth segue you
think I could have ordered these games
differently but no here we are look at
the tentacle blood monster fantastic
your form grows as you consume the nasty
lab technicians who imprisoned you as do
your abilities though you'll want to
watch out for bullets and other
obstacles as you traverse the gritty
facility a pc demo released late last
year to rave reviews that were
particularly impressed by the style and
fluidity of the move
it the entire vibe of the stealth
action-platformer looks to be pretty
bloody engrossing pun fully intended so
if you're keen you can get to squishing
dudes on PC and Xbox one later this year
next up is a game you probably don't
need me to tell you about but just in
case the final act of Kentucky route
zero is arriving alongside the release
of the TV edition which will bring the
series over to ps4 Nintendo switch and
Xbox one if you're not already in the
know Kentucky route zero is described by
developer cardboard computer as a magic
realist adventure game where you travel
through a hidden highway beneath
Kentucky and meet plenty of interesting
strangers along the way the series which
began releasing in 2013 has been almost
universally praised for its strong
storytelling brilliant score and
evocative themes if you haven't waited
in yet the final act arrives on January
28th so if you're one of those people
who likes to wait for their episodic
games to finish releasing before you dig
in you couldn't pick a better time to
try it out
finally here's one for the strategy fans
and mafia era fans and doom fans and
Wizardry fans Romero Games the studio
built by John Romero and Brendan Romero
are creating a 1920s era strategy game
by way of ex-con called Empire of sin
you step into the shoes of one of a slew
of mob bosses who are actually inspired
by real people and manage the goings-on
of the mob business hire new recruits
and expand your empire into a range of
different options by taking territory
from your rivals the game was first
revealed at Nintendo's Direct
presentation at e3 last year and appears
to combine its XCOM s combat with
roguelike elements that randomize the
starting conditions as well as
incorporating RPG elements empire of sin
is coming to ps4 Xbox one switch and PC
this year so if the idea of kicking off
a crime organization in 1920 Chicago
where alcohol is currency sounds like a
good time to you keep an eye out for
this one if there's a great-looking
under-the-radar game coming out you
think people should know about do drop
it in the comment section below and let
me know
any of these games are going on yo to
playlist for 2020
[Music]